where will you go what will you achieve
it's up to you this is your adventure
your journey your very own treasure hunt
vast natural expanses and vibrant
cityscapes await here in the paldeo
region
[Music]
your journey begins with enrollment at
an academy in the heart of valdea
you'll meet your teachers
ask mates
and senior students
after clavel will announce the
independent study assignment the
treasure hunt
and so your quest to find something you
might always treasure begins
start you'll select your first partner
Pokemon
sprigatito
Fue Coco
or quack sleep
[Music]
the legendary Pokemon cried on or
meridon will also help you during your
travels
[Music]
with the support of your Pokemon you'll
be able to explore more and more places
you can Adventure through paldea in any
way you want
where you go is entirely up to you
[Music]
with local Wireless or online play you
can explore paudia with up to three
other players
[Music]
there's something waiting for you around
every corner
challenge Gym Leaders at Pokemon gym
[Music]
there are eight gyms in all tackle them
in whatever order you choose
[Music]
team star is a group of troublemakers
disrupting the Academy's activities
infiltrate their Hideout and defeat
anyone who stands in your way
say hello to Arvin an upperclassman
searching for rare herbs
join him in tracking down these
mysterious herbs said to be hidden
across the paldeo region
[Music]
in paudia you'll encounter all kinds of
Pokemon
the chalk uses its trusty sense of smell
to find food
Fido feels moist and smooth to the touch
sit Titan boasts a massive body and
solid horns
paldayin Whooper lives on land and is
enveloped in a poisonous film
approach a wild Pokemon and a battle
will commence
[Music]
you can also have your Pokemon engage in
battles on their own
[Music]
terasolizing is the key to dominating
battles
this phenomenon found only in the paldea
region causes Pokemon to Sparkle like
gems
[Music]
it also make their move stronger
all Pokemon can terasterize some will
even change types entirely when they do
these particular Pokemon can be caught
in Terra raid battles which can be
challenged with up to three other
players
work together to defeat and catch wild
Terra Pokemon
[Music]
capture memorable moments from your
adventure with the camera app
you can access this anytime while you're
out and about
need a makeover stop by a beauty salon
to change up your hairstyle and look
snap a photo with your Pokemon while
you're at it you can use the photos you
take to customize your profile and
create your own ID card
[Music]
picnic and relax with your Pokemon
give them a good wash
or make a yummy sandwich together
[Music]
both will deepen your bond with your
Pokemon
foreign
[Music]
region is calling what treasure will you
find
Pokemon scarlet and Pokemon Violet
available November 18th only on Nintendo
switch digital pre-orders are available
now on Nintendo eShop
[Music]